what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i'm going to talk about a topic that i
saw unfresh in a bit but before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification
now while you're at it that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
okay so topic i saw in freshman pit they
were encouraging
young men to sleep with 50 girls
before they commit to one
so i thought about this for a while
because
um the question is is that beneficial to
young men
right obviously from
this is so awkward for me to say but
like a pleasure
standpoint yeah i mean i think most guys
would enjoy having sex with 50 females
duh okay second thing is in terms of a
note negotiation
power play i would imagine you probably
get less attached the more you have sex
with people so i
i could imagine 50 girls each one's
probably going to mean less to you
correct sorry my gps goes
so you can correct me if there's any
studies i'm just using my logic skills
like if you had sex with one woman
ever that would probably be crazy cool
like you would probably have such strong
feelings and emotions
if you've had sex with 50
i can't imagine it's the same
um so i know
that they also say on the channel that
they prefer women with low body counts
and they prefer women that
are virgins right but that's becoming
more and more rare these days there
aren't very many women
past the age of i would say 21 that kept
their virginity
and that's clearly very that's clearly
very valuable
um no doubt right
now i was involved in i was catholic i
grew up catholic
and i became christian
i don't know i was 22 maybe when i
converted
i know a lot of girls not a lot i would
say a good amount of females
that actually waited till they were
married and stayed a virgin until they
were married
and i can tell you that the guys on
fresh and fit podcast would never
they would never be able to pull a girl
like that because a girl
would look at myron and the other guy
and i could tell you i know the type of
guy
that my like virgin friends married and
he was not flashy he was not charming he
had a good strong
foundation a great faith in god and
he was just like like they're genuinely
kind
the guys of these girls marry and i'm
actually i'm thinking about having a
couple of these girls like on the
podcast
so it just depends what outcome you want
if you want a girl that's a virgin like
you can't be getting girls
pregnant they're never gonna they're
never gonna
consider you to be a husband you can't
be
hooking up with girls left and right
they're never gonna consider you to be a
husband
you have to have a relationship with god
if that's the reason they're saving
themselves
and that's not that's not something
that's easy to think
and that's what i mean in dating in my
opinion you reap what you sell
so if you have sex with 50 females
the type of girls that are attracted to
guys that have had sex with 50
100 females they might be good looking
but what's their character like
and what quality of women are you
attracting
so my two cents um i would be very
surprised
if they could get an outcome where they
married a virgin
i would be shocked because all the
virgins i know
probably married guys that you guys
would say would be beta
but they got a better outcome than you
sorry if the virgin thing that's the
most valuable thing to you
they got a better outcome than you did
so who really won i don't know let me
know if you disagree in the comments
you can let me know but i'm probably
going to have
a couple friends that i waited till
they're married to have sex
on my podcast to actually talk about
what they look for in guys
so yeah if you guys would be interested
in that let me know in the comments
because i was thinking it'd be a really
cool piece of content but
yeah i will talk to you guys next time
love you guys don't forget to subscribe
bring that notification bell
i'll talk to you guys later